i don't understand this how could we be
getting these results is 32 gigabytes
really worth the extra 400
for your m1 macbook pro well today we
will find out because i have the same
exact macbooks in front of me other than
one being a 16 gigabyte model and the
other being a 32 gig model and i'm gonna
test a wide variety of applications with
different background tasks running and
different amounts of web browsing tabs
to find out do we see a difference in
performance and is it worth the extra
money once in for all this video is
brought to you by squarespace the best
way to make an amazing website i'm going
to start out by restarting both of these
machines that way we have no background
ram usage or any swap on the ssds and as
we go through these tests i will show
you guys the activity monitor to show
you how much ram is being compressed
what is being written to the ssd and all
of that let's start out by opening up
five safari tabs this is fairly normal
for me that way we have a little bit of
ram used here i also have some
background applications open i have my
fan controller i have istat menu that
shows me temperatures and other info
along with adobe creative cloud running
here as well checking out the activity
monitor both of these have cache files
and seven and a half to eight gigs used
so let's go ahead and open up lightroom
classic i have 50 42 megapixel images
opened up right here all of them have
effects to the raw files and i'm going
to start out by getting a reading on the
export speed here now i'm using
lightroom because it is a program that
definitely is very ram intensive the
most ram intensive let's hit that export
there and in the past we have gotten
faster speeds with higher amounts of ram
without even other background apps open
whereas with all the other programs if
you don't have a bunch of stuff open the
speeds were the same so let's see what
we get interesting as we're doing this
export look how much memory pressure we
have on the 16 gig model this just shows
how tough it is on the memory so we have
a lot more pressure here and we're
writing already over three gigs to the
ssd
using 14 gigs of ram compared to the 32
using almost 22 gigs of ram and we have
nothing written to the ssd now this year
the ssds are twice as fast and the
memory bandwidth is twice as good as the
m1 chips so uh it's less of a difference
when you have to write so let's see if
we actually have any performance
differences now i want to let you know
that we're also going to test a 32 gig
against a 64 gig m1 max macbook pros and
in that video we're going to test
windows 11 with parallel so if you guys
want to see that make sure you guys
enable those notifications and while
you're at it you might as well subscribe
and comment below if you want a chance
to win a 2500
m1 macbook pro all you have to do is
comment on our launch week videos each
video gives you another chance to win
and we will be choosing one of you guys
no matter where you are in the world
alright guys we do have a difference and
it's only two seconds one minute and 23
seconds compared to one minute and 25.
so right in the gate we do see a
difference but it is literally only two
seconds if you spend an extra 400
and even if you had 500 of these huge
images that's only like 20 seconds saved
and even though we did have to write to
the ssd on the 16 gig model you see the
performance hit is almost non-existent
now if i'm working in lightroom i'm
often working in photoshop as well so
let's open up five of these high
resolution images and then we all know
that chrome is a ram hog but i still do
like to use it just like many of you
guys i went ahead and i opened 10 tabs
in chrome i have multiple tabs that have
auto loading ads and stuff open i have
an auto loading video in the background
here i have a couple tesla tabs open
youtube with an excellent video running
if you guys didn't see the macbook air
compared to macbook pro video you guys
should check it out i also have a
spreadsheet open a long script and then
my google drive which has a ton of files
open in it so let's just go ahead and
keep scrolling we're going to load up a
bunch of stuff there don't forget we
still have five tabs open in safari and
this is pretty much the max amount of
stuff that i have open if i'm doing
photo editing photoshop and lightroom
open up instantly on both swapping
through photos are equally fast we're
getting no lag no delay and with all of
that the 32 gig still has no swap used
even though we have multiple
applications that are professional open
we have 15 tabs two auto playing videos
whereas we have eight gigs of swap on
the 16 gig model now what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna go ahead and do that export
one more time to see if all those
additional things in the background are
gonna slow the 16 gig model down all
right wow
both of them actually got slower this
time but the difference is only three
seconds now instead of two a minute and
28 compared to a minute and 31 i was
expecting a much bigger difference now
now before we get into video exporting
let me give a shout out to the sponsor
of this video squarespace if you've been
thinking about making your website
squarespace is seriously the best way to
go you can build a great looking website
like we did with literally no web making
experience it doesn't matter if you want
a portfolio a blog e-commerce or
anything else you just choose from one
of their great templates and easily
customize blocks of text and images it's
incredibly simple it's affordable and
ours have been running flawlessly for
years now bringing in tons of traffic
thanks to its built-in seo tools start
your free two-week trial with no credit
card required by go to squarespace.com
maxtec or by using the custom link down
below and when you're ready to launch
you will save 10 off your first purchase
of a website or a domain let's go ahead
and open up final cut pro even though i
would never have photoshop and lightroom
and final cut open let's just test it
out here i have a 5-minute 4k pro res
raw project open it's set to better
quality on both not better performance
so we're getting full playback and right
now as you guys can see both are playing
back perfectly smooth i do have color
grades applied to these let's play this
back in double time and i'm still not
seeing any skipping or dropped frames at
all and now let's export this five
minute project i am using prores that
way we're not limited by the h.264
encoders and with that said you guys
know that the ram that are in these
systems this is shared with the graphics
and as you see our graphics are pinned
so having all those applications open in
the background can definitely affect the
amount of ram that the graphics card has
in order to do this export but if we
zoom in look at that they are almost
neck and neck and both just blazing
through this 4k pro res raw looking at
our activity monitor both of them
actually have swap used one is at 15 and
a half gigs the other 32 gig model is at
six gigs so both of them have to write
to the ssd with lightroom and photoshop
and all those tabs open wow right at the
end there we had some little spikes you
see those lines in there and then we had
a slow down on the 16 gig model because
of that the 32 gig model was faster i
finished in a minute and three seconds
compared to one minute and nine seconds
so there you guys go with all of that
open and those spikes in memory pressure
the difference was only six seconds and
right after that our 16 gig model
cleared out a bunch of stuff from the
ram look how much lower that dip got so
more of that is in the swap and we're
only using eight gigs of the physical
ram compared to 18 on the 32 gig model
so it's gearing up for more work what i
want to do now is go back let's go ahead
and open up photoshop on both bam they
both open at the same exact time so it
doesn't look like we have to read from
the ssd or if we did it was incredibly
fast let's switch photos here
same exact time switching over for both
that's crazy and what about opening
lightroom
bam they both opened at the same exact
time that is crazy and flipping through
these photos i'm not noticing any
slowdowns on the 16 gig model let's zoom
in here
super responsive on both now those of
you guys that use lightroom you'll know
that when you have a lot of stuff open
brushes can really slow down let's see
if we notice a difference at all between
these
i don't know guys to me they both look
really really smooth guys if this is an
intel based macbook pro these would be
chugging along right now super slow that
might be because even the best i9 it had
a memory bandwidth of around 42
gigabytes a second compared to these
machines that have 200 meaning you can
clear ram and you open up stuff much
much faster and of course the ssds are
twice as fast as well so we have
lightroom open there we have photoshop
open we have final cut open of course we
still have those safari tabs open let's
go ahead and see how those are
performing i'm going to switch over to
the verge which is very heavy bam it was
instant there let's switch over to my
little house plan site man that is still
loaded let's open up the ram hog chrome
here wow
the google drive is still open scroll
down nothing got cleared here at all
what about our youtube video that's
actually playing in the background still
man that is ready right there how about
ign with the background video still open
let's go to their home page
still open on both this is crazy the
performance here with the unified memory
is incredible everything is instant no
slowdowns at all even if some of this is
from the ssd from the swap that is crazy
alright guys i would never push a system
this hard i would never be able to
multitask with photo editing lightroom
video editing and all this craziness but
for this video we are gonna do that
because this is a multitasking stress
test so i'm gonna go ahead and open
logic pro let's play this benchmark that
has 50 tracks with a bunch of stacked
instrumentals open let me turn on the
speakers for a sec that's a hot piece of
gear that's a hot piece of gear you were
brent wow high school with brad
we got those two videos still playing
back there this is loaded up in the
background and now let's open up xcode
as well just in case you want to work on
an audio project a programming project
and photos and videos at the same time
both are pre-indexed and let's go ahead
and build this i'm going to set my timer
it looks like both of these failed i'm
not sure why i'm not really a programmer
so let's just go back to the standard
way where we have the terminal command
that maxum marimenko created for us
along with this benchmark bam we are off
our cpus are maxed out right now
compiling the code we still have
lightroom open photoshop opened chrome
with a bunch of background tasks and
final cut open and logic open and look
at that guys the memory pressure is
slightly higher on the 16 gig
but the 32 gig still has pressure and
it's still using five gigs of swap
compared to 16 gigs of swap on the 16
gig model so literally it's acting like
a 32 gig system now for those of you
guys that want to avoid swap and you
want to spend you know an extra 400
bucks to avoid it well if you're pushing
the systems enough to maybe see a
difference you're going to be using swap
anyways and even on my mac pro with
192 gigabytes of ram it still sometimes
uses swap even though it doesn't need to
which is absolutely crazy oh look at
that our 16 gig model just dumped extra
ram um and i don't know what it did with
it because it's not in the swap maybe
that means our chrome tabs were just
closed down we'll go ahead and see all
right guys we are done pushing these
systems to their limits what is the
result of this compile test well our 16
gig model took 137
seconds compared to
115 seconds on the 32 gig model so this
compile was 22 seconds faster with a 32
gig
that's not that much time that is 19
faster so if you have a crazy crazy
project you'll have a 19 difference if
you have all those other applications
open in the background but with that
said these apple silicon systems are
insanely fast at compiling code so most
projects are really quick let's go back
to google chrome and let's see if any of
these have to be reloaded because we saw
that big ram dump on the 16 gig model
nope we're watching snazzy labs on both
without a hitch
every website seems to be
fully loaded more background video here
if you guys saw my previous comparisons
against intel systems also with the m1
comparing eight gig and 16 gig even
before we pushed it this hard when we go
back to chrome we would have to reload
tabs on the 8 gig model but it looks
like 16 gigs of faster ram and having
the much faster ssd we're literally
seeing no differences at all and nothing
is noticeable when it reloads if it even
does guys i don't even know what else to
throw at it i guess let's open this 8k
prores raw final cut project we have
four 4k clips in an 8k timeline
basically the same exact kit on the
system as an actual 8k video with color
corrections applied to all of these
clips they're both playing back
perfectly smooth all right let's go in
double time this is basically twice 8k
and
geez okay with pro res it doesn't care
it's playing back perfectly smooth how
about this i opened up a whole different
library and let's open up an ak project
that is not prores so the encoders and
decoders can't work for that this is
canon 8k footage from the canon r5 let's
play it back on both
and look at that well
neither one of them are playing this
back perfectly smooth and how about this
very tough r5 10 bit 422 footage
look at that i saw glitches on both at
the start which i don't blame them i
can't believe either one of these
systems are doing this good with all
that background stuff open and both
these are playing back perfectly
actually on this model i even have a lut
applied which i don't on this one so
let's make it fair and enable it on both
of these systems and just this project
alone in this footage make intel
macbooks just stutter even my fifteen
thousand dollar mac pro stutters with
this and look at this they're playing
back perfectly so the last video expert
i'm gonna do is with this really tough
footage this is a five minute project
and i'm going out to h.265
to allow the graphics to have the
biggest hit possible with fast encoding
they are both exporting at the exact
identical time
dang since this is gonna finish at the
same time let's just push this to the
absolute extreme i would never do this
in my life ever let's go ahead and
export with lightroom at the same time
with all those background applications
open as well just in case you're
absolutely insane and check this out
guys we're using 14 gigs of swap on the
16 gig model and about eight on the 32
gig model neither of them are maxed out
on the pressure yet i do not believe
this our graphics card usage did go down
to 56 percent 60
that's because we don't have enough cpu
resources to give enough work to the
graphics our final cut export slowed
down dramatically because of that but
what is this the 16 gig model is ahead
it's slightly ahead now instead of being
at the same exact time i don't
understand this how could we be getting
these results oh actually the 32 gig
model caught up there at the very end
and it beat out the 16 gig model by one
second three minutes and 54 seconds for
a five minute project compared to three
minutes and 55 and wow lightroom is done
on both of them as well i didn't even
catch that um i don't know if one was
faster than the other but it didn't seem
to be the case at least maybe by only a
few seconds okay guys if this does not
answer your question on 16 gigs versus
32 i don't know what will we have these
50 edited raw files open these are large
42 megapixel images we still have
photoshop open on both look at that no
delay to load that up and switch between
the photos look at that instant the
exact same time we also still have logic
pro open with this project bam there you
guys go we're playing this back
we still have those background videos
multiples playing at that same time of
course we showed you guys final cut pro
open right here all of our tabs are
still there in google chrome
even at this point look background
videos working
none of this is being delayed or slowed
down on an intel mac it would be crazy
look at that no difference at all same
thing goes for safari
that is just absolute insane performance
well as you guys see i would never have
all that open and be doing a video
export and a photo export at the same
time with logic open
and photoshop open and all these tabs
and oh geez
yeah i gotta be honest with you guys i
thought there was gonna be a bigger
difference than this at least with all
of that open i was for sure thinking the
16 gig would finally slow down but it
doesn't and that's thanks to the double
the speed of the ssd and that crazy 200
megabit per second gigabit per second
bandwidth of the ram
and as far as swap if you're worried
about your ssd you know having 16 gigs
loaded instead of eight that's not going
to make a difference and either way
there is going to be some swap and even
like 10 years ago with the first ssds
that were rated for like 60 terabytes
written when they did endurance tests
they actually wrote i think between 600
and 1000 terabytes between those before
those gave out in this case these are
way better the latest and the best and i
would say for almost everybody
even with this torture test it would
just be worth getting a 16 gig and
spending that extra money on more ssd
space because when you double the ssd
you also double the terabytes written
capacity the life rating of your ssd i
think that is a much smarter investment
or if you just want to save some money
save that 400 if you're not going for
the m1 max that requires 32 gigs and you
know spend it somewhere else there you
guys go uh once again if you guys want
to win a 14-inch macbook that's 2500 you
guys could do so by commenting down
below um and with that click that
subscribe button you guys need to be
subscribed above and you guys can help
us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers we would definitely
appreciate it check it one of those
great videos over there we'll also have
32 gig versus 64 gig on that one max
this is max and i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]